c'est quelquefois on dit il ya des
choses qu'il ya des choses qu'on
n'explique pas et les choses il expliqua
les choses que quand on n'ose pas parler
tellement elles sont étranges
il ya quelques jours je le redis t il ya
quelques jours jean tracy je rentrais
chez moi et leur prouver tier 2 heures
du matin il y avait un brouillard un
brouillard à couper au couteau et en
tout d'un coup j'entends fils d'abraham
fils d'abraham
comme j'étais tout seul je dis oui
chic et plus j'entends une voix
lointaine je suis jéhovah combien de
témoins
je vous écoute la voix me dit tu es bien
le fils d'abraham
j'ai entre autres et je ne suis pas le
seul nous sommes tout un peuple à être
le fait que la brave et la voix me dis
justement c'est un appel au peuple que
je viens danser j'ai pourquoi moi il
n'est pas ce qu'on a trouvé personne
d'autre bon voilà je voudrais te mettre
à l'épreuve comme j'ai mis jadis ton
père à l'épreuve si le père neuhaus et
non le père abraham
j'ai dit c'est cette histoire ancienne
jb oui tant souvient-il
j'ai les premiers à bram eu de
descendance innombrables du fils des
petits fils des arrières petits fils
sont un peuple à condition qu'ils me
sacrifier à son fils si je sais il n'a
pas fait
vilon parce qu'au dernier moment mam un
refus sans bras je devais vous avez eu
un beau geste
sans ça je ne serais pas là
je revois me dit voilà je voudrais tout
soumettre la même épreuve sacrifie moi
ton fils j'ai vous trouviez malgé parent
d'enfant à il me dit c'est parce qu'on
m'avait dit enfin bon enfin je dis ça
fait rien sacrifier moi ta femme j'ai eu
là d'accord j'ai défoncé en parle dit-il
oui bien que c'est pour la bonne cause
lui dit vous sûr que ce soit la bonne
parce que déjà que j'ai épousé pour le
bon motif au rct pas le bon mais de
toute façon au dernier moment
ma main retiendra-t-on bras j'ai dû vous
pouvez me signer un papier dit ce qui
est écrit est aigri alors j'en ai parlé
à ma femme elle l'a très mal pris
ouais mais couteau sous la gorge depuis
sacrifier pour toi
si en plus faux que le couple enquête
pour ta famille jeudi enfin te rends-tu
conduite sacrée promotion ou un fils de
famille devenir le père du peuple
elle a compris l a compris c'est elle
même car mais mon bras elle m'a dit
vas-y vas-y
il m'a dit tu es sûr que tu es derrière
toi je sens son souffle en dira pourquoi
ici tu fais parce que je suis pas sûr
que sa main soit assez fort pour retenir
membres